話の長い好調です
ハンコばっかりをしています
こちょに見えます
見ますかありがとうございます
よかったです
そんな好調に見える私もですね
日々いろんなことで
悩んだりー
苦しんだりしています
皆さんもいろんなことで
なんかトラブルに巻き込まれたりとか僕とこうしたいああしたいあると思うんです
人は
やはり解決に向けてなんとかしたいって思いますよね
そんなとき
自分の心の中にある根っこの部分にある物ってすごく大切なんだなあって
思うんですよね今日はそんなことに関係するお話をしたいと思っています
読むこと
書くことで
心が変わり人生が変わりました
とても
いろんな思いが
めぐっていて
教育に取り組むということは
教師である前に人間として
どうかということが問われると思うんですよね
だから常に
しっかりしなきゃ駄目な頑張り俺って言ってるんですけどもくじけそうになるんですよ
ね
でもなんとか
思いとどまることができている
それもきっとこの
心の根っこの部分にある
何かあったんだろうなと
ってそれがやはり私の原体験なんです
それを今日はお話しします
まず何か
困ったことが起こったときとか辛い時に
思い出すことそれから
教育の中で意味ある学びとか
学びのあり方とか学びのデザインとか
そういうものに取り掛かっていくときに
必要なものってなんだろう自分なりの正義を見つけなきゃいけないんですよね
常に私の原点が
あってそれが2つあるんですよ
一つはは私の名前が答えになっています
k 1と言います惠一と書くんですよね
私の母親は流産を繰り返しました
でもー
最後は
もうこれで最後できなかったらダメだね
そういう思いで生まれた子が私でした
だからこのようにたった一つの恵みとして授かった行
一つの恵み k 1
そんな重めでつけられた名前なんですよね
だから
授かった恵みを
今度は誰かに
授けてね
つないでねっ
言われました
それが
母が残した言葉です
もう一つあります
今日の上にもなりますけれども
小学校時代の
恩師が
私を助けてくれました
その音も
返していかなければいけない
自分の名前として
恩師から受けたことすべて恩送りとして返していく
と決めてます
そして
人生において必要なのは見えない力
そして心の根っこを育てることだ
木場普通
地上に入ってるものが見えますけど
下の方は
ねっこって見えないですよねでもすごく大切ですよね
水を養分を吸収して
で小さい頃の私実は10歳まで人と話をすることができませんでした
せっかく
k 1っていう名前もらったのに
まあ子供の頃はまだそんなことも知りませんけども
自分の人生ある意味絶望的で暗黒な時代っていうのを実際くらいまで過ごしてました
声に出せないんです涙しか出ないんですよね
ちゃんと言わなきゃわかんないでしょ
人に何か伝えたいんだったら言葉にしなさい
怒られてばかりでした
でも
人生っていうのは何かしらテンキー
迎える時ってあるんですよねそれが小学校5年生の
担任の先生が
私を支えてくれたんですよ
ちょうど新しい担任の先生だったので家庭訪問があって自宅まで一緒に歩いて帰りまし
た
道すがらいろんな言葉をかけてくるんですけど言葉でも全く返せない
本当はここの中で先生と会話してるんです
先生ごめんなさいほんといっぱい言いたいことはあるんです
先生は
いいました
しゃべれなくてもいいよ
今は無理しなくてもいい
頭の中でいろんなことを考えているんだろう
その代わり
今は
一生懸命本を読め
そういったんですよね本の中には
いろんな出会いがあって
いろんな人がいていろんな考え方があると
そういう正解を知ることが大切なんだ
入ってくれました心の中では
ありがとうございますわかりました
いました私はその先生の言葉を信じて
本を読むことに没頭しました
読むこと
これが現ターク県の出発点です
小学校高年生から6年生にかけて
おそらく200冊くらいは読んだと思います
その中でドストエフスキーの罪と罰と
カラマーゾフの兄弟というのは全く読みきれませんでした
最初でもギブアップでしたところが中学高校大学と重ねていく中で読めば読むほど
新しい発見がある読書ってそういうものなんですよね
り読むことは
世界を知ること
そしてその次が大事なんです書くこと
これは未来をつくる
先生から言われて読書して感想文を書いて先生に出すとコメントを返してくれるんです
よね
だから嬉しくて一生懸命
また読んで書いて読んで書いてにねかそれ繰り返しました
今考えたら先生よくそんなことをやってくれたなと思います
そして漢字が難しいんです言葉がわからないんですっ
行ったらある日先生
を進み家に来たんですよ
ここ辞典持ってまあ新しい
皆さん広辞苑って知っていますこんな大きい
こんな大きくないかあっ
この今これぐらいの大きさでこんな暑くて
まあ子供にしてみればとんでもない何か百科事典みたいなの
持ってきたんだって感じに覚えてものすごく嬉しかったんですよね
箱に入っててそれを取り出して扉を開けたら
先生の直筆デー
書いてあったんです
一重
辞書に親しめと
それだけの文字なんだけども
もうありがたくてありがたくて
でそれから数日間はの子自演ばっかり読んでました
さすがに感想文が書けなかったんですけども
そういったの
読むことで
書くことで何が養われるかっていうとまあ心の音が
太く長くなりますよって話につながるんですけども
読むこと書くことっていうのは自分の中にある
抽象的なちょっとわかりにくい抽象化されたものが刺激を受けるんですよね
でも刺激受けただけでああよかったじゃダメなんですよ
それを取り出して
初めて生きてくるんですけれども難しい言葉ですから取り出したときにやっぱりそれを
どう表現手を相手に伝えようって考えるんですね
書くことは思考することなんですよ
こうやって話しするよりも書くことのほうが実はすごく難しいです
その代わり時間かけて遂行ができます
手直しできるんですよね
そういう形を
何度も何度も繰り返していると
自分の言葉というものが生まれてくるんですよね
だから未来を作れるんだろう
思います
私は文学の
力を信じています文学に救われましたから
文学には人生で
生きていくための
人としての根源的な問いが建てられています
いろんなドラマがあります
いろんな
人間の生き方
人間の
強さとか弱さとか
美しさとか醜さとか
人としてのあり方聴き方そんなものが会ががってますよね
そういうことを考えるようになります
そして
選んだことを見たこと聞いたことを体験したこと全部を外へ出さなきゃいけないんです
けども
取り入れたものを
確かな成果にするためには
インプットとアウトプットの比率っていうのが黄金比と言われているのが3対7だそう
です
input さん output 7もう圧倒的に出す方が多いですよね
だから外に出して初めて人間の思考っていうのは
注す抽象的なものも全てクリアーになって分かりやすい
ただ言葉っていうのは
あいまいで不完全なんですよ
なかなか伝わらないですね言葉を合わせるためにどうしたらいいだろう
私と今
聞いていらっしゃる皆さんの間にも言葉の格差ってあるかもしれません
それは自分が育ってきた背景
努力という言葉一つとっても多分
それぞれの皆さんが
肌で感じている動力って多分違うと思いますねここに100人いたら100通りの努力
ルっていうのがあると思いますだから言葉を合わせるってすごく難しいと思うんですよ
でも合わせなきゃお互いに分かり合えないどうしたらいいだろう
私もいろいろ考えました
教壇に立っていたときには
生徒にパイカクカクことを要求しました
その代わり私も一生懸命書きました今も書き続けてます
そんな中で思ったことは
アニメとか
コンピュータの画像処理でレイヤー2あの画像を重ねていく作業があるんですよね
それでアニメっていうのは作られてあのパラパラッを
のようなもんですね原理は
そして
一つの作品ができあがるという
で言葉も同じなんだろうなと思います言葉を重ね合わせて言って
曖昧なものが
だんだんだんだん
わかりやすい具体的なものになっていく
言葉ってそういうもんなんだろう
だから
思ったことポーンというんじゃなくてそれに重ねるようにして相手に理解してもらえる
ような表現キロも考えなきゃいけない
書くことっていうのはそれぐらいいろんなエネルギーを必要とするんです
皆さんはどんな形で
アウトプットしてますか普段
私はいろんな形があっていいと思うんです
文字にして書くことパソコンで入力することこれもアウトプットですよね
そして話すこともそうです
それ以外に進退表現というのもあります
今日もヨーヨーのパフォーマンスありましたけれども
あれも訓練した賜物をアウトプットして皆に何かを感じてもらっているわけですよね
アウトプットすることによって心が変わる
人生が変わる心の猫が二遠くなって吸収力がどんどんどんどん強くなって栄養のある4
に伸びていくんですよね
だから栄養はどこにあるかこれは自分で一生懸命
目を凝らして
自分に合った営業を見つけなきゃいけない
ぜひ皆さんもアウトプットしてください
それが
心を変えるきっかけになります
アウトプットして
人生を変えてみてください
あなたの言葉と私の言葉を合わせて重ね合わせて
素敵な未来が作れればいいなと思っていますありがとうございました
[拍手]